welcome back to new rock stars it's me
Mt and Spider-Man across the spiderverse
finally dropped their first trailer and
I have never been more excited to see so
many men in tight spandex in my life
like look at all those spider people Man
and spider ladies and Lady spiders but
hold on now what are all the established
rules of the spider-verse anyway I mean
if portals have been opening snatching
up innocent newly divorced Pizza eating
depressed dudes anybody can be sucked up
into a spider verse Shenanigans at any
moment even new so let's lay down the
spider law in preparation for across the
spider-verse shall we by nerd babies but
speaking of the across the spider-verse
trailer my homie Jessica Clemens
recently broke down all the Easter eggs
from that spider-verse trailer because
she is an absolute boss of a spider
machine so I highly recommend that all
of you guys check that out after you
watch this video as well as Eric voss's
extremely in-depth deep dive into all of
the animation from the across the
spider-verse trailer as well so check
out those two amazing videos on our
Channel as soon as possible to learn new
something good and if you want to be
wearing something good be sure to head
on over to new Rockstar's merch com
today to check out all of our new latest
Obsession shirts as well as all of our
other amazing nerd options over there on
New rockstarsmerch.com all right so I
would say the first and most important
rule of the spider versus obviously if
you leave your Universe your molecules
are not going to be happy with you this
is of course a core plot driver of into
the spider-verse when all these spider
people not native to miles's home
Universe designated Earth 1610 started
to have their physical forms
disintegrate and glitch out because
their atoms did not like being in the
1610 Universe wow
complete cellular Decay and obviously
you've been glitching glitching no why
would you even say that you stay in this
Dimension too long your body's going to
disintegrate do you know how painful
that would be Peter Parker I don't know
human beings were not meant to travel
across the spider-verse to different
universes because that is literally
against the natural law of the universe
the Multiverse but hold up now then how
come we see all those spider people just
chilling out Max and relaxing all cool
Envy across the spider-verse trailer
presumably they too are going across the
spider verse just like miles and Gwen
are so why are they not glitching out
well I believe this leads us to rule two
of the spider-verse which is you need
one of Spider-Man 2099's wrist bracelet
gizmos to be able to Traverse the
spiderverse without your body glitching
out and falling apart and that was a
rule pretty much established in the
post-credits scene of age of the
spiderverse when we first meet Miguel
O'Hara Spider-Man 2099 and his sassy AI
Lyla tells Miguel that he is about to
make the first autonomous jump across
the Multiverse and she says this
specifically after the events of each of
the spider-verse as flashes of Miles
Gwen Peter and the rest of the gang
stopping Kingpin jump into view on
Lila's holographic monitors this wrist
Gizmo seems to be the key to Miguel
being able to jump across the
spider-verse without having every single
atom in his body disintegrates into
nothing because he is not native to any
of those universes and if you look
closely at all the spider people in the
trailer notice that they all have the a
unique variation of Miguel's bracelet
Gizmo fastened on their left wrists very
much implying that Miguel's bracelets
are very much necessary for them to all
congregate in this alternate reality
without glitching out these bracelets
are going to be extremely important in
this next spider-verse film because
miles and Gwen are about to go on a road
trip across this bang spider-verse and
of course these bracelets also serve the
super helpful function of facilitating
travel throughout the spiderverse as
well as we saw first at the end of into
the spider-verse when Spider-Man 2099
hilariously meets the Spider-Man from
the original old school Spider-Man
cartoon who the heck are you I just told
you that listen listen how dare you
point at me you were pointing first rude
to point you're being very rude alright
guys I'm on camera a lot so I have to
see my face a lot so you think I'd have
to put a lot of effort into my skincare
routine but I don't because I use
geology geology is a 15 time
award-winning personalized skin care
company recognized in hypebeast birdie
Men's Health Esquire and ask man
grooming Awards with over 6 000 5 Star
reviews that is a lot of thousands
that's six of them and they've recently
expanded to offer products for pretty
much whatever you need all you've got to
do is take a quick 30 second diagnostic
quiz and geology figures out your
routine for you if you need Hair Care
not me use geology's co-wash a specially
formulated cream cleanser that removes
buildup and cleanses the hair without
the big lather or harsh ingredients of
typical shampoo and for the rest of your
shower routine you can use their body
washes that are free of harsh
ingredients smell great and are
refillable and for after the shower
protect your skin from environmental
stressors with vitamin c and e for Rolex
serum to keep your skin looking young
and healthy and then a bit of
dermatologist tested aluminum-free
deodorant that quite honestly smells
great like I've gotten so many
compliments from the ladies specifically
so and right now for a limited time
geology is hooking our audience up with
an absolutely insane insanity if you use
code new rockstars they will give you an
additional 70 off their award-winning
skin care trial set that's seven zero
percent seventy that discount applies
whether you're stocking up for yourself
or stuffing someone else's stocking
instead either way geology has you
covered check out their awesome gift
sets featuring all your favorite geology
products to get started just click the
link in the description take a 30 second
diagnostic quiz and their team of
dermatologists will design a
personalized routine Gene just for you
that shifts directly to your door now I
think having this bracelet on the
physical body of the spider person is
extremely important here especially as
we enter our next rule of the spider
verse DNA is required especially if you
want to navigate the spider-verse In
Search of other spider people and the
use of DNA to search for individuals
throughout the Multiverse was actually a
big part of into the spider-verse as the
DNA of Chris Pines 1610 Peter Parker was
accidentally used to summon forth all
the spider people from their respective
Dimensions at the beginning of the movie
because if you look closely while 1610
Peter Parker is fighting Green Goblin at
kingpin's Alco Max Facility Green Goblin
accidentally shoves Peter's head into
the middle of the alcamax super collider
and Kingpin is not very happy when he
does this
foreign
because during that experiment the super
collider was locking onto the DNA of
both his dead wife Vanessa and his dead
son Richard to lock in on other
Multiverse variants of his lost loved
ones and this is why right before
Kingpin kills Spider-Man Peter Parker
implies to Kingpin that he saw variants
of Vanessa and Richard when his head was
inside those were the variants that
Kingpin and Dr Octavius were trying to
Channel with the DNA in the strands of
Vanessa and Richard's hair however Peter
Parker's spider DNA got thrown into the
mix which caused the super collider to
lock in onto the five spider totems of
the five universes that were already
colliding with the 1610 Universe while
the door was open the universes of Peter
B Parker when States see Spider-Man
Penny Parker and Spider-Man Noir as
indicated by their Earth designations on
the ALCO Max computer screen here Miles
Morales native universe is of course
Earth 1610 like it is in the comics and
that is referred to as the Ultimate
Universe and it is the universe where
Miles Morales was first introduced to
the world and the universe is being
drawn towards miles's 1610 Universe are
as follows Peter B Parkers from earth616
which is the main Marvel Universe of the
original Peter Parker Spider-Man so
Peter B Barker is essentially the Sony
spider-verse equivalent of that and then
of course we got Gwen Stacy from Earth
65 which is likely a reference to the
year when Stacy was introduced 1965.
then we have Earth 14512 which is where
Kenny Parker and her spider's Sentinel
horror come from but check this out gang
I noticed this last night because if you
use a alpha numeric Cipher you'll notice
that these numbers 14 5 and 12 spell out
n e l now for sentin now which could be
Penny's nickname for her met in spider
Ham's home Universe of anthropomorphic
animals designated Earth 8311 is named
that because of the month and year that
spider ham first debuted in 1983 in the
11th month of November 83 11. and of
course Spider-Man War hails from 90214
which is a reference to the close zip
code of 90210 a reference that I believe
belongs to the show Beverly Hills 90210
that the actor Christopher Daniel Barnes
was on was of course the first ever
actor to voice Spider-Man Noir in the
video game that inspired the very
concept of the spider-verse Spider-Man
Shattered Dimensions after of course his
original claim to fame being the iconic
voice of the 90s Spider-Man from the 90s
animated series but this leads us to our
final and most important role of the
spider-verse do not leave your super
collider door to the Multiverse open
like Kingpin did during his
experimentation because that is how
multiversal incursions are start to
happen which is what we were seeing in
the first film the five Knew by spider
verses beginning to merge and converge
with the 1610 universe and not only this
but if you leave the door open long
enough the entire space-time Continuum
will be destroyed but those are all the
main rules of the spider-verse that you
need to know to survive going across the
spider-verse are you guys excited for
across the spider verse let us know
you're across the spider-verse hype
levels in the comment section below
thank you guys so much for watching this
video you can follow me at mesotainment
on Twitter if you guys want to see me
tweet some weird [ __ ] into really fun
theories but more importantly you can
find new rockstars wherever we are on
the social media and of course do not
forget to watch both jesser Clemens and
Eric voss's breakdowns of the into the
spider-verse trailer Jessica with the
Easter eggs and Eric Voss with the
animation breakdown they are doing
amazing work over there and I love these
breakdowns so much watch those
breakdowns immediately but again thank
you guys so much for watching this video
I love you guys so much and I'll see you
guys next time goodbye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]